We talked last week about a poll that showed
that 64 percent of current Republicans are
willing to leave the Republican Party if Donald
Trump were to start a third party.
And this reinforced the sort of soft nature
of much of the support of the Republican Party,
as well as the cachet that Donald Trump, at
least now as we approach one month since he's
been out of office, that for at least now
Donald Trump still has on the Republican Party.
But that is all hypothetical.
Those are people who would be willing to leave
the Republican Party.
What about people that are leaving and not
because Trump started in another party, but
just because they're leaving?
There is a very interesting series of studies,
many of them out of California, some out of
Florida as well, which show that there are
already thousands and thousands of voters
in some counties that are leaving the Republican
Party.
And what where they are going remains a question.
And we're going to talk about that in a moment.
But this seems to be a reaction to the defeat
of Donald Trump, combined with two months
of lies about the election supposedly having
been stolen from him.
And voting experts at the University of Florida
say that there are thousands and thousands
of Republicans that are no longer traditional
Republicans that are no longer registered
as Republicans anymore, and that while there
are often changes to party registrations all
the time, and in particular after elections,
that the number of Republicans leaving the
party are significantly greater in number
than the number of Democrats that are changing
their registrations.
They looked at San Diego County in California,
as well as some other parts of the country,
and it appears as though the January 6th Trump
riot was sort of like the straw that broke
the camel's back.
It's unclear that it alone is the explanation
for why so many Republicans are abandoning
their party, but rather the sort of culmination
to months and really years of a complete joke
of a Republican Party with Donald Trump at
the helm at its head.
And it is believed, indeed, that the abandonment
of the Republican Party by these folks is
a sort of rejection of Trump ism more than
it is of what the Republican Party used to
be.
These folks who are leaving widely believed
to still be in line with whatever values or
ideologies brought them in in the first place,
whether it was Ronald Reagan 40 years ago
or whether it was someone like either of the
George Bush's or more the Newt Gingrich style
early 90s politics that attracted people to
the Republican Party or folks like John McCain
and Mitt Romney, more recent Republican nominees,
whatever it was that brought them.
And they still they're not leftists.
They're not leaving because they're leftists,
but they're leaving as a rejection of Trump
ism is what it seems to be.
Now, there's a really important and obvious
question to ask if we want to figure out what
is or is there an electoral impact to this,
which is OK if you leave the Republican Party,
are you still voting for Republicans?
Unless we have reason to believe otherwise,
they probably are.
You can leave the Republican Party and be
an independent and still vote just for Republicans.
And I can't imagine that many of these folks
are looking to vote for Democrats at the state
and local level.
Maybe some would stay home, which would still
be a help to the Democratic Party.
And sadly, I believe most of these folks will
be very quick to return if indeed what they're
doing is rejecting Trump ism by leaving as
soon as the media focus gets back to Black
Lives Matter is terrible.
And Joe Biden's allowing immigrants into the
country and owe the debt and the deficit and
all of that tried and true stuff that we predicted
Republicans would go back to after Trump and
that we're already seeing them go back to
after Trump.
I believe many will return to the party.
And importantly, I don't think many of these
folks will opt to vote for Democrats rather
than whatever Republicans they can vote for
in twenty 2022 and in 2024, assuming Donald
Trump is not the nominee at that point in
time.
So, you know, you know, independents who used
to be Republicans that still vote for Republicans,
not super interesting.
And it's important to know as a general political
concept, when we talk about independents,
there are some folks who like to frame themselves
as these enlightened centrists that are not
loyal to either party.
And sometimes they vote for Republicans or
for Democrats or Green Party or whatever.
The vast majority of independents vote overwhelmingly
for one party or the other, and they are essentially
as partizan as most Democrats or Republicans.
They just aren't officially a.
Affiliated with any party, and let's not overstate.
The importance of party registration alone
now that being said, if a lot of Republicans
are abandoning the party, if some of them
are saying for the time being, I'm not going
to be donating, these are things that could
make a difference.
The question then becomes, will Democrats
take advantage of it?
And that certainly remains to be seen.